good afternoon everyone
thanks for coming to my lead station uh
we'll be evening Friday I hope you're
all awake
if not I'll make sure that this might be
a cure during insomnia
just kidding just kidding I got a couple
of URLs over here I know we had meant
that as part of the description I wanted
you guys to have your laptop set up but
I don't expect you to do it now because
I'm going to be here for a while so I'm
going to give you a choice to just
dislike's actually a part of this
particular GitHub so you can actually go
to that particular GitHub all the
notebooks are over there you can
actually follow them in class yes they
are run as they are and their slides and
they actually want to follow and
um
obviously this is what we're going to
cover today now this tutorial normally
is about for an entire day I normally do
about five to six hours so I don't
expect to cover six hours of materials a
day in an hour and a half but I'll cover
the first module which has three
tutorials that will sort of give you a
feel of what Ray is all about right so
before I um
tell you who I am and who I actually
work for I just forget an idea of who
you guys are
so raise your hand if you have never
heard of red
words okay good how many of you have
heard of rail using red
lovely lovely and how many of you can
continue yourself data scientists or
practitioners and ml engineers
I'm going to ask a very tongue-in-cheek
question
it's like going to a Catholic mass and
asking is it what the Catholic yeah all
right so brilliant that's actually a
good idea
um
so what I'm going to do now is just tell
you who I am what my background is when
I was introduced I'm currently a lead
development look at any skill prior to
that I was leading the advocacy group at
databricks where I was deaf for about
six years
um contributed to Apache spark and I'm
not flow and also the league of their
full learning Spark and then LED level
of advocacy at homeworks and then prior
to that I was you know SWV at some of
the notable companies was very fortunate
I was very lucky to
get back in in the
in sort of in dates me where I am
you know where I come from so who do I
work for I work for a company called any
scale which is the original creators of
Ray
and those of you who are not familiar
with real those effectively familiar
they actually emerge from UC Berkeley's
rice level instead for real time
secured and explainable intelligent
systems and rice lab is a pre uh
apprentices or or a successor to another
land which is very research and
disoriented UC Berkeley called antler
anybody heard of antler yeah mclap
stands for algorithms machines and
people amplib was responsible for
notable software open source projects
such as Apache spark which led to the
founders of big researchers that they
found in the company called database
mesos
was another project that actually came
from there
um Cafe was another project that
actually came from there so the app lab
was about for 10 years and it sort of
addressed certain problems in the big
data processing and and the
orchestration which led to Apache spark
and
that and then there was a new Revolution
coming to the Forefront which was
machine learning and rice lab was the
successor of Kansas
where Ray was created
with red are the are the people actually
founded the computer
and what do you do
um
I think I would make a case that that
unified compute platform
in the distribute to manage a difficult
thing to do and we wanted to make sure
that the next generation of people who
are going to be able to developers right
from the get-go feel easy to be able to
actually use this particular unified
field the distributed computing is hard
and so our mission was to make sure that
that this necessity that has actually
emerged because of your enter the Zeiss
guys of NL Computing or distributed
computing should be easy you should be
able to write distributed complications
as you would actually be right back home
and that's that's the mission that's the
mission of the political
company now I'm not trying to pitch that
but I think it's very important to give
you the context before we get into the
code is to what is great and wiring what
were the motivations behind because I
think it's imperative to think about the
historical reasons why this particular
project has come to the Forefront and
why is that you're beginning to really
um uh build the momentum in the ml
community so I'll start with with 20 000
feet and I'll sort of gradually to send
down to 10 and then we'll go
talk about code and apis and scaling
patterns and like I say this is like an
old day six hour tutorial there's no way
I'm going to cover all the material I'm
going to cover the first three notebooks
but before if you actually get a chance
if I can help hold you captive during
the break I'll I'll voluntary be here
and then the other modules available
extra material is there for you um
so feel free to do that
so let's talk about you know why you're
ready what was the reason behind these
researchers who were at UC Berkeley in
the Forefront of the valley where they
were looking into how the trends are
actually going and there were
essentially three fundamental driving
factors that say why you actually want
to read just like there were three
fundamental factors before purchase
parking today as part of the antler
likewise there were three fundamental
driving factors in the industry and in
Academia where that actually led to one
was the realization and the reality
obviously that machine learning is
becoming pervasive how many would you
dispute that today
that machine learning has become
pervasive it's in our lives it's another
everything we actually tell
and that particularly led to the
necessity of distributed programming
because the machine learning models that
we actually built today and we will
build tomorrow
I'm not going to fit on your laptop
right and I'm going to fit on your on
your on your Edge devices there might be
a a version of it or a slice of it that
might be but most of it is going to be
distributed computing and distributed
computing used to be an exception before
maybe time of HBC and early days of
distributed computing but now it has
become a necessity it's not an exception
so that led to the necessity of that
we are a pipeline
data and again I would contend that
pythonia is a default language for
foreign
language might be different obviously
July or something but they had python by
you that's a necessity so those were the
three bets that the Founders actually
better than that
now today we are fortunate right today
we are fortunate with it being endowed
with this blessings of scale
now today's models you know I mean your
laptop might be able to compute 100
billion instructions a second but some
of the flops that that you need to do to
train those models and need to execute
models are in this particular
exponential scale
but blessings on scale also introduce
another problem which is the supply
demand problem right and if you look at
how the models and the kind of compute
power has evolved over a period of
decades you can actually see that the
linear growth of these language models
and Foundation model is enormous in
terms of how my computer power you
actually need and they've been CPUs and
leaving gpus along the way that somehow
has helped us a little bit but
fundamentally there is a huge gap
right this Supply demand has actually
created a huge gap
and what do you do with that particular
Supply demand
other contention is that the only way
you can actually deal with this that you
actually go
compute across right you have to
distribute and it's because of this that
you actually have a necessity to do
distribute computing and distributed
computing for those of you who have been
working on it it's not easy it is hard
because we actually started with early
years in HPC and use API you know those
things have existed for a long time and
it took a lot of expertise and took a
lot of in-depth skill to be able to
write those and our mission was to make
sure that this becomes really actually
easy for people
and we want to address that we actually
want to address that you can actually do
take your laptop and extend it to your
cluster where you can actually do things
in your laptop and still run on the
cluster of an asset scale so that's
that's the thing and then obviously the
third the third fundamental factories is
you can't dispute that right
just with the factor there that those of
you who are data scientists and those of
your mission learning
on a daily basis and if you're doing uh
deep learning program you're always
dealing with these pretty good um
so those are the three fundamental
factors into something extent I could
say no because I'm trying to plan to
ingratiate myself with the Affairs but
they were quite patient about saying
these are
these and so I talked about why I read
those are the fundamental reasons and I
just want to talk very briefly about you
know what it is very obviously you can't
talk why and what before you how things
so I think about what is really and I
think one thing I I want you to take
away two things I wanted to take away
from this particular presentation is
that it is a general
simple general purpose library for
disability
it is not tied to a data structure it's
not tied to a data friends no trying to
any particular logical structure just
like sparkies with data frames or
downscapes that with different tasks or
drags it is time to uh a Primitives that
we actually provide that allows you to
write any distributed company that you
use
and straight out of box it actually
comes with Naval libraries that
the daily and machine learning so it's
very much into its two personal people
who want to distribute the compute at
scale so it gives you the computer power
and the libraries that allow you to
scale individual workloads who you are
and the great thing is that he actually
runs on the laptop on any public Cloud
that you're familiar with on kubernetes
if you like that on-premise and
obviously on your laptop
I look at it
as a layered kicker functionality in
capabilities for security machine
workflows and I want you to keep that in
mind because I'm going to come to that
in momentarily it is a layer kicker
functionality what I mean by that
so if you look at it at the bottom we
can actually run on any particular
platform right any public Cloud that you
actually have which is the the one at
the bottom
if you go one level that's what I'm
talking about the general purpose
um compute layer which comprises of
Primitives such as tasks that you talk
about those you look at the notebooks
actors and objects and these are the
Primitive abstract
allow you to provide
the etos the philosophy
of really is to provide you with those
abstractions so you don't have to worry
about scheduling you don't have a reason
about performance you don't have a
reasonable tolerance you don't really
have to reason about where your tasks
are going to run how they're going to go
what resources they're going to be how
you're going to Auto scale all the hard
bit that you expect your distributed
computing framework that can be
structured to take care of Ray does that
you as a developer write use these
abstractions to write your distributed
computing and then if you go one level
above what you have is you have the the
new libraries that we actually have the
unified new libraries that we've
introduced with major.org which has now
been beta called the rate air which is a
runtime engine and those are built atop
this particular layer so all the
libraries that we actually have for you
to do your your machine learning
workflow are built on top of rare core
which means that you can scale it the
way you want
and you can actually take your laptop
and running running on
the cluster now if you don't care about
data science if you don't care about
machine learning all you care about your
Python program and you just want to
write
locations that you're on the far right
hand corner you can write this you can
use The Primitives to actually write
those
so those are the fundamental I talk
about layer cake or functionality
a little bit about what these are
um the runtime libraries that we
actually introduced called uh Ray run AI
runtime
are very uniform unified libraries that
actually work really cohesively together
prior to 2.0 we had this individual
Library we did that we did it so we
train our linked tune and served and
they kind of were siled right they were
kind of silos that didn't work very well
but now in 2.0 we have actually
coalesced them together we have created
unified apis that the input of this can
the output of this could be an input to
train if you're using train you can
actually use the r link which it
actually uses you know the
policies to train something you can use
tune do you have a permanent tuning and
you can actually view the server so the
very very integrated together very
declarative they're very expressive
um and they're very composable whereas
before they were sort of unique Union
pillars and you get to do a lot of that
so that's what I meant right I talked
about layer cake
and if you go one level above you have
this landscape now this is not a
marketing slide but there is a reality
over here is that we have straight
Integrations with some of these
third-party Integrations that you as a
developer or you as a as a data
scientist we don't want to use that
right right it comes straight out of the
box straight integration so if you want
to use your data sets to do last mile
injection for your training you can
actually use your data set it works with
Das it works aob's data stories that you
actually have
we integrated with that straight out of
the box you can actually use that she
goes to training with the pyth Georgia
with the train uh if you want to tune
you can actually use the aquapartment or
two that that we support with all the
algorithms that you have and including
the schedulers
[Music]
you're only stopping all that's actually
required
and then if you're doing experimentation
where you're keeping track of the what
parameters with tuned you can actually
do that with ML slow and weights and
prices and if you're using survey we go
straight introduction to that so that's
sort of the layer cake or functionality
I'm going to talk about what we're going
to consider today in the first three
molecules is the lower layer because
the core and
I just sort of get into it
let's go about that so I just wanted to
get an idea about this layer kicker
finish navigating
so any questions so far
lovely okay so I'm not let's uh let's
drop down a little bit
so what isn't it now until we have a
rare cluster look like now if you come
from a distributed computing background
this is not very different from let's
see the spark or your Tasker uh
um infrastructure but a few things quite
unique about Ray which distinguishes
itself um from other distributed systems
is this is this what we call a
distributed scheduler so each and every
node actually has two uh uh two two
processes one called red arraylet which
is like a scheduler and he maintains the
object store and job dextrose is the
shared memory for that particular node
and the red legs are the one that
maintain the resources and schedule your
task and the work in the distributed
schedule so there's no single point or
driver unlike spark you actually have a
single pointer driver that actually
parses your your DSL creates a stack
creates a graph creates a static um DSL
gives it to the analyzer and they create
and then fans up over here any any
worker can actually be a scheduler and
the share Object Store which is quite
unique that allows people to ship
objects across the entire store so if I
create a particular object of node a
eventually over time another task of
running on working node will be able to
actually get that very easily
so this is quite unique uh in terms of
in terms of to rate and it's quite
performant because it's based on Apache
era and we we continually pass the
objects across the entire cluster if
they actually need it elsewhere
the global Central store is essential
Store where the meta directory of
everything is actually happening in
in stone over there so I know at any
point within 10 milliseconds what node
Ray that has resources or task is
running what the actors it's running you
know how many CPUs how many gpus
available so I can actually
schedule the next task of years and met
our stories like the brain of it really
broadcast that across the cluster so any
point at any time really actually knows
who's doing what and if I need to
schedule something I know actually who
to send the particular request to
so that's kind of in a nutshell was the
high level
um infrastructure now Ray out of the box
supports these distributed design
scaling patterns and apis and design
patterns are not something new to us
right design patterns or something that
was introduced to a stream of
consciousness of early days by the game
before who anybody read this book
yeah so you know these were sort of
opinion in way of how you actually would
use a language right
in Python we have we have
decorators we have curators those sort
of design happens now with Ray the
fundamentals and three design patterns
year tasks
and tasks are dysfunctions which are
stateless and they can be actually
executed on any particular functions you
actually have a python function you can
go to
the end scheduled around anywhere
they're sticklers and functions can be
distributed across the second thing is
Futures objects which is distributed
I've talked about the the shared memory
Object Store these are available objects
which can be stored in the cluster and
they're materialize when the value is
either computed or stored in there so
they're asynchronous in other words if
you put something in the store or if the
task creates an object and puts in the
store you actually get a reference back
and then reference and materialize at
some point in the future and this allows
us to do a massive parallelism at scale
because when you have a secret insidia
I'm just gonna
give you the reference and then check up
and check on me later that long
and by contrast actors are State Food
Services which you want to consider and
allow you to do a message passing
uh and these are some of the links that
that took these at length you'll have
access to those lines and what are some
of the scaling design patterns
now those of you who are machine
learning uh practitioners and data
scientists you probably have seen this
happen so right for batch training and
inference we call this different data
and send function so if you're doing
distributed training which is DDP you're
actually using different data but you're
using the same function to train it
so this is a distributed training or if
you're doing batch and friends this is
no different like you're actually
sending shards of data different data to
each and every function which is
actually the same thing this function
could be a model or this could be some
loss function but it's competing the
same thing with just you're running on
different data
compared that to send data different
function you use where you actually have
uh different data on the same data where
you're working on different models let's
say you're doing you want to evaluate a
business problem doing some logistic
redirection that you actually want to
predict but you want to use three
different models to find out which will
actually give it
the best right so what you do is you
train three different functions you see
the same data and you take the best
functions of the best algorithm
really tells you that it's going to be
the best metric that you actually have
and the the third one which is a
combination of this is where you're
actually doing hyper parameter tuning
where you're actually using different
data because your trial is going to be
different where it's the same function
the attribution the same training you
look but you're just changing type of
parameters of space to do that so batch
tuning and that are kind of similar so
how do they manifest their cells in
Python
so if you look at this particular code
over here I just have a function in
Python called f and I'm going to convert
that into a distributed task all I have
to do is I just decorate the function
called radar remote
and when when the driver schedules that
or executes that one or where was
actually on the Node even though
oh thank you
yeah
that would be scheduled on a particular
note right on that particular note and
so similarly if I actually have an actor
or a class a python class that I want
this to be a
class
stateful class in a remote cluster all I
do is just do the radar remote and then
when I create an instance of that and
then we actually create the instance
that I just use the cluster
that gives me gives me an instant in
this instance can be
um
attached to a worker node
across the cluster
and then same thing if I actually want
to create a distributed immutable object
all I do is I take my number area which
is a large file that a little Berry that
I can do with numb tensor whatever that
is I just go to a rate output very
simple and then I can do what rate I'll
get right the radar put is their
synchronous if you just return your
reference right away right and it says
this is where the particular object
story is I'm going to do a ray.get it
knows where the reference is and it will
block radar get as a blocking call
so when I when I do rate or get if the
object has not been materialized then
so that's in a nutshell about about the
apis so here's a little more code that
actually serves you I have you know a
radar of a function called read array
that actually text in a file and there
is a particular file and returns a
number or on the right from that number
area and then I have a function that
just adds two numpy arrays right and the
way I invoke that particular function is
is I just use the postfix dot remote
which now tells me that this is array
function and it's going to go ahead and
return me the reference right away it
doesn't it's not synchronous it will
return right away something I could do
radar array so I have two fonts that I'm
reading and not that I'm on the remote
function either radar and I'm just
sending in the references
right I'm not saying the actual data I'm
just sending the references and when
those data is ready radar get will
actually return you the value is totally
with ADD functions over here and
likewise if I had a function if I have a
class that I want to go ahead and create
that as a safer function I just do
regular remote and then that returns my
instance and I can just use that
instance dot method
to execute the classes methods is that
I'm sending a pretty good message very
simple API very pytonic right the only
difference between the usual uh
invocation in Python is you don't have
the dog remote you just create an
instant coffee's encounter left bear and
bike pairing over here just use the
remote and if it takes any argument you
specify in the in the remote function
so just walk through it when I execute
this what's actually happening is that
this particular readout area and
everyone could be scheduled on node one
right could you schedule another one so
it's going to read that and return you
the idea right one returns you in the
future immediately and the second one
could be Elsewhere on another note right
if it's not the same data so now I'm
actually running the second function and
the second node and I'm just returning
you uh the the reference right away and
then when I do a radar get and function
is going to get the reference for those
two and return You Back
that's very simple as simple as that you
don't have to worry about that you just
you're just writing python code as if
you're you're being a very iteration
very eagerly but all that is actually
happening in the background oops sorry
so one bit about uh distributed Object
Store
um Ray or object store or the workers
have this idea about ownership right and
ownership means that any worker process
any task any action that actually
creates the object
maybe in the function when you have to
return or you create an object is the
one who actually owns that particular
object and it will store it in the
shared memory of its node if it's a
small object Which is less than 100
kilobytes then it's going to show it in
process memory but if it's larger than
that then it's going to store it in the
shared parts of my memory which is
shared by all the processes because this
is running on the same note all the
processes
share the very shared memory so if I'm
one process this worker process to get
the value of y I can just use zero copy
because I'm using it straight from the
shape memory so that's very performant
that way and likewise if the data gets
if the shared memory on their particular
node gets filled because you know you're
creating a lot of object it does get
spilled over into shared disk and all
that references what's actually stored
where is handle you don't need to worry
about it you just write letting code
which I'm not trying to sell you but you
know that's the beauty of it right the
Simplicity of the and it sort of reminds
me of my early days and I'm dating
myself for the early days
um when you when Linux or Unix was
created like you know you know the
Timeless people to unfortunately uh rest
their piece
um they came up with a very simple
interface they came up with the fight
the FBA has defined the scripture and
you get all these apis that actually
dealt with the transcript and the file
description will be what
it could be a file descriptor
self-evidently true uh it could be a
second
it could be a pipe it could be a pointer
to the database and the apis actually
does that and the operating system was
the one that actually does the context
switching and and writes and reads the
memory out of that similarly you just
write this primitive functions and the
ray if I could call it the operating
system will take care of the schedule
so there's some sort of analogy there
and the Simplicity of the apis that
actually led to an enormous revolution
of all the things which are actually
built on total games you and I would
have been sitting over here it hadn't
been for
the male guys
agree
and to think about this let's
listen okay so here's an example of what
I mean by distribution right so I have a
function called remote I'm returning
ownership remember ownership returning
this x is going to be stored on the Node
on which that particular node on the
particular function they will schedule
I have another function called G and
what I'm sending to G I'm not sending
the function which the value of x but
I'm returning a reference to it and G
now is going to be the next one that's
going to be scheduled now because Rey is
intimately familiar with where objects
are located it will take advantage of
locality so this particular remote
function is going to be scheduled on the
same node where X is leaving so I don't
have to copy X or somewhere else
right I just get it from the same shared
memory so that becomes the kind of
performance it is a contrived simple
example but that's true for any large
computes that actually happened
okay
what should I do with Rey
telling me all this thing what am I
going to do with Ray there has been
envelope evidence of what people
actually use
we are actually a heartman we're
actually quite surprised just in three
years
how it has actually taken off
shouldn't
world
things you can actually do with it you
know so there's a runtime was completely
written on top of red right on the same
platform and we can actually scale it
because Ray was fundamentally built on
the ability to give you the compute to
scale
right you can write your distributed
cycling and replacement using job lib
distributed XC version Ray right now the
distributed exhibit can run on
multi-core single node but with this you
can actually use multi-core multi-nodes
right
multi-processors pool you can actually
do that when you're ready
180 Services people are in the industry
actually using Ray as an interest is a
core to do that these are all the
companies that are building their
infrastructure with array right we were
actually quite surprised
um we just had a summit
um two months ago three months ago and
we were actually quite hardened see
these are the early adopters who are
actually using me and if you look at
this company they're dealing with scale
if you look at open AI you know they
jump into a gp3 model was actually some
of the models were built using red to do
that because the fact that it actually
wanted to compute and don't believe me
look at uh look at the video that that
Gary gottman actually said we looked at
a lot of this with computing set up with
Ray because it gives us the ability to
scale right sending Amazon Stitch fix
all these guys talked about you heard
about coher talk about yesterday
they're actually using the tuning
um IBM is another one that's actually
using the QX which is the Quantum
Computing they're actually using where
to send their jobs over there so these
are some of the companies that that have
validated of a premise
that Ray is here to compute that scale
so you're dealing with scale you deal
with rig
okay Quick Check of it I said
distributed computing is a necessity
because you enter the Zeiss guys Ai and
ml this time we won't have called AI
Adventure we're going to have a warm
Adventures for a long time to come and
we're going to be doing this because our
vision is simple make the simple
Computing simple right
it's Allen K say simple things in the
simple
complex things should be possible and I
think we are aiming for our own case the
second thing that you can actually make
make simple create complex things simple
and the genius and Ingenuity lies on the
ability to take a complex things and
make it appear simple it's not easy and
stuff but that's where the challenge is
and we just want to be able for you guys
to scale things
okay any questions before we get into
code
yes
the right thing
if it's too big one for a single for a
single worker like the the memory the
memory is too big yeah so what will
happen is that if the memory is too big
let's say that you know 10 gigabyte
um if you're if you're you'll probably
get out of memory because you can't fit
in or it will spill things to the disk
right so if you have if you have a large
object which is which is
uh doesn't fit in memory it's going to
spill over that if you shared memory
Studio because when you start the red
cluster you can see how your shared
member is going to be if that doesn't
fit then yes you'll get om just like in
spark you do the 10 gigabyte font boom I
kind of load the standard friend you'll
get no end yes
yes
okay so the No Limit use case are are
what do you consider time series No No
Limit use case would you consider motor
Carlo distribution is not only use case
right so would you consider Computing
buyers you know
right you want to compute pi to the 28th
digit right you distribute using what
the column across or you have some HBC
computation that you don't care about on
MLK
you want to do Mac reviews for example
in scale which macro using a general
purpose right I can do anything with
mapreduce I can use maps for my tax
calculator
and we'll have one example in The
Notebook
but don't worry story you should be able
to run it okay
yeah yeah I'm wondering how
uh what is the main difference with spot
you know I can do more so we can spot as
well
now I'm not here to
um page one against the other right but
I'll see that In fairness
if my grandmother asked me Julie what's
the difference between spark and and red
how would I answer that question right
and then I'm going to ask the question I
would answer them to to a developer
I said Grandma you got two children
Julian jewels
but Julie is brilliant at doing x y and
z Jews sucks
or or is no competent enough to do that
oh he's not doing a very good job and
vice versa
so
to answer your question now what's it
why would actually use that both
distributed systems
address the different workloads for
different purposes it's very consumable
that certain workloads in spark will be
far more severe than than rare now
go one step further if I was doing ETL
and if I was building data legs if I was
doing SQL workloads if I were doing
stream processing would I use the right
hell no
I would use far anytime
right if I was doing hyper parameter
Distributing a master scale if I was
doing reinforcement learning training
get a massive scale if I was doing a
Last Mile ml ingestion right after my
data has been completely killed using
YouTube using Spar I would use red so
there are different use cases and the
extremely extremely complementary one
way to think about it is that your
ml Journey Begins the way your function
ends
in the data part of the world right so
if you cleanse all your data you're
pretty clean all your data you don't
know your future engineering and it's
the last thing you're actually doing
before you start sending data to the
distributed trainer is to do that you
might do some last month pre-processing
you might change your numpy's area into
tensors or you might uh change your
pandas into tensors that you actually
want that that's the last of my
pre-processing that ml data set
right yeah to answer your question yeah
thanks okay anymore
okay
is the formula
oh
play
now the instruction is how to set up a
machine but I want to figure it right
now and I don't ask where you do the
exercises because I don't know
we recover the material this could be
something you can actually do at home
we're good
okay
where's my notebook
can you guys can see the font
okay so briefly talked about
you know
um how actually the new apis convert
your your existing functions
into python code and the objective with
this for the exercise is to sort of goal
with this very simple apis about how you
actually use remote decorators to do
that so what I'm going to do over here
is is
import some
necessary arguments and I'm just going
to talk about what Tasker parallel
patterns are and how that kind of
different so when you actually invoking
a python function you use your normal
python function by just invoking the
name of the function and when you are
converting that into into a task
function okay rate function what you
want to
do is
include the operator use the suffix and
then and then invoke that particular
function so that the two different
things one is the distinction in in name
location
regular python functions are just
invoked by the name of the function
whereas Ray tasks are are invoked using
more
function and the mode of execution is
like
it's like one return one is synchronous
legally executed the other one is a
synchronous and it returns you a future
right away so you don't wait for it but
then whatever the future return can be
fetched when it's actually materialized
when it's actually run
so here I'm just defining a very simple
functional some of the examples are
rudimentary but I think it's important
for just to get the mental picture of
what's actually happening so I think
that's an important part
so here I'm just a regular function and
I'm going to convert this function into
array by just converting that into
a remote task by decorating with that
and they're actually identically the
same I'm going to go ahead and start my
array cluster and I can just say if Ray
is initialized
or shut down because I don't
want it and ray. in is your silly little
client that's actually going to talk to
you because now this is all going to run
on my local machine because I have 10
cores but if I wanted to connect to the
cluster which is the whole language
extending your laptop to the cluster uh
we just hit the cluster URL to the Head
note and it would now talk to the
cluster if I wanted to have gpus
assigned for my rip I can actually
provide the resources over here if I
have some environmental dependence or
packages I can actually
we won't get into that there are some
links over in the module that you can
actually do that so this sort of returns
you a nice thing I'm running you know
python version of this uh 2.1
yeah
oh interesting okay
must have updated okay and then this is
a link to my cluster
my dashboard that allows me to look at
how things actually running so right now
I have 10 cores as I said there's a
worker known Creator on every node so I
actually have one
iPhone process which is dedicated to to
a core if I say the rate up in it none
CPUs is equal to three obviously workers
running so by default it companies the
number of nodes I have in running
okay brilliant so let's go ahead and
just use this function using python
syntax
keyword uh let's use this remote
remember I told you just returned your
object reference right now this is an
object reference that has has encoding
it about you know where this particular
where the object task is
the internals can can figure out where
to get it and I'm just going to do a
radar get to get that and I should
actually get one
right very easy now if I actually want
to do a Serial on python which is not
parallelism I would do that in a
particular Loop where I am executing you
know sort of 10
um
is synchronously means that you can see
it takes a long time because it's going
to sleep for 10 seconds and return to
the value one and my assertions would
actually return true and if I actually
wanted to do this using red
I can use comprehension and what this
comprehension will do is for for 10 is
going to go in in book
10 tasks each task will be separate each
task will be scheduled on a particular
court and it's going to run right and
it's going to return you a list of
references that I can now use radon get
to get that as simple as that
right very pythonic
things to do
okay you saw this example let's do that
in real life I have an array that I'm
just going to do a read that array who's
going to load this particular area I'm
going to send out send send the send the
path to my uh my function let's define
this particular function
it's taking a path it's going to do the
numpy array
um I'm going to Define
and that actually takes in two numpy
areas now remember you know I'm sending
an argument type over here but Ray will
know that if I send if I send an object
reference it knows that I'm sending an
object reference and that way it's going
to go and resolve that before it
actually does the computation so you're
smart enough to say what you have sent
me you know are you sending me by value
or if you're sending me by reference
so that you find function and then I'm
just going to go ahead and sum those two
arrays
and I should actually now
be able to read this particular array
and I get my reference back
which will be expected
and I read the second array and I get my
reference back
and I'm just adding those two two arrays
together using the remote function I
just remember I'm sending object
references over here right
then returns me an object reference now
I'm going to fetch the value
and that sort of returns you and that
gives me the ability to yeah now this
numpy area could be a large computation
I'm just giving you an illustration that
this is a simple case but you get a
million entries over there and you could
do that or you could be another task
that you're actually Computing this
would be a great for doing macro juice
right we fan out maps and you just wait
for a reduced to do that we'll look at
one example what I mean by that
and I just do a radar get to get that
and I should actually have these values
right any questions
lovely let's look at another sort of
more more involved where this is very
similar way actually competing
fibonaccia series if you want to do that
using uh eager execution using regular
Python and you want to use
grateful here so we're going to write a
generic function Logistics the sequence
of the thing you're going to create when
we create
a covers
and I'm just going to use the same
function but I'll just wrap around using
radar remote
now this is going to convert that into
array task
this returns me how many CPUs that I
have so I can actually fan it across my
my number of CPUs so I'm going to run it
locally first
and when I run it locally see how long
it's going to take
all right it takes about 1.9 seconds not
bad now if I run in distribute it
is very remote it takes 340 41
milliseconds because everything is
happening is parallel like can you just
change the results where's the other one
yes
um
of course so is there like a rule by
which you like decide when to bring it
right
or if you have two cores how do you
actually decide yeah or like how many
like how many observations or how many
times
without you tonight
and by default by default when you do
radar in it and you don't provide how
many CPUs you have it's going to figure
out using this particular method to say
okay I have 10 codes I'm going to create
10 working processes right now if you
somehow don't care about using all the
10 processes you're just going to use
five to create five cores and then it's
going to schedule according to whatever
the code is available yeah right so you
can schedule that and remember relay is
the one that knows I have five cores
that's got four CPUs I'm going to go
ahead and create a sign for different
tasks because that video is looking at
can use forces I guess a lot of people
are like when does it make sense to
oh yeah when does it actually make sense
yeah so that's one of those you know
tuning things uh you know it's it's it
it is kind of a black heart like like in
Sparky said well how do I know how many
partitions actually to create right you
just have to play that by the year right
so you you try their first local
information to see
how running your tool cores or running
with full course skills and then I
actually want to scale to a machine you
connect to a particular cluster you
might have four nodes but each node
might be a let's say a 5x
AWS machine that has 16 cores and it's
going to create 16 processes and that
way you know you you can scale it so it
depends on what you're doing right these
kinds of things really don't need that
but you should be able to actually do
that so if you're competing Pi you could
do Monte Carlo simulations that require
you just compute down obviously you want
to have more compute you know more tasks
to run
now this is a very simple uh ubiquitous
example of Mac computers right you can
actually write Maps
um functions using tasks and you can
just use reduce to do that this is a
very common Paradigm I think the
gentleman was asking me you know what is
what is some of the um
known ml stuff that you actually might
use you can actually use metric use
let's say you have
parse or large
Corpus of data and you want to reduce
those things you can actually use Ray
Map Reviews
now this has been sort of deprecated
because because in 2.1 Ray data we
actually have mapreduce built in into
radiator so you can actually do massive
EXO Shuffle with 10 terabytes of data
that they actually does the shuffle but
this is just a small example that I
wanted to illustrate
what you actually do
um
so what I'm doing is I'm just creating a
list of items that I that I'm creating a
Lambda function which is going to my map
function I'm just going to just add each
each item separately and I just do that
single threaded map
right this is single thread effect which
which I'm using python
then I'm going to do the same thing in a
parallel with a sort of more elegant
where I am going to create my map as a
remote task
and I'm just going to go ahead use the
link extension use the number of items I
have you know I have I'm going to go
ahead and create a separate
item separate map tasks for each of them
I'm going to send you the map function
that I'm going to do right and then I'll
do a get on it so this internally will
return me a comprehension list of all
the tasks which have been created with
object reference to it and then when
they're ready I'll just go ahead and do
that
which is exactly what this particular
bid does
if I wanted to do a single thread
interviews I would use something very
similar in the python I would actually
create a list create my Lambda function
execute the Lambda function and then do
a lot then do a sum which is a very sort
of linear way of doing those things and
I can do
but if I want to do a parallel map
reduce I do the same thing except now I
convert my remote into a reduce and I
just send the elements that I actually
want and it's just going to
sum them together
so here we actually do
um remote first
it returns me all the object references
for that and then the final reduce
I send in my remote elements and I just
do a get for the sum and I return the
result exactly very fast
or if you actually wanted to do the
chain videos which is sort of you know
combining those into smaller smaller
chunks of data than actually do do the
small reduced bit over here which is
breaking up into small chunks and
creating each of those and then creating
a reduced um in parallel
and that would be this pretty good bit
right where you actually have created
those into small chunks of trendy
elements and then actually doing a
reviews on that all that has actually
happened happened in the background
I know this is this I'm throwing a lot
of stuff but you know when you actually
go through the code and I think one
thing good about about a tutorial like
this for an entire study day is that you
have exercises at the end and you work
on it right you write your own
particular functions you get a feel for
it right as opposed to over here I'm
just imparting that thing
you know one and a half hours a bit a
bit too much but the good thing is that
guys you have this materials you can
actually go on and do that now this is
um another use case where
how do you actually use tasks to do your
distributed batching from the batch
inference is something very common in ml
right
you told we talked about if you attended
some of the um sessions this morning or
the company over the last couple of days
batch reference is an important part in
the ml part of it once you're actually
building your virtual model you want to
do bashing from offline or you might
want to do in
them and using tasks that you can
actually do with the batching difference
so this is the common
um use case where you actually it might
have an input data set
since we're in New York I might as well
use what data set
anywhere you guys
who said that
actually you get a sticker you get an
extra sticker yeah
primary is full of Art
okay
and then the model obviously you did the
model and then we'll do the prediction
that you you did oh you read that off
that that's fine you must take me back
that's cheating you're right I just said
to me you should never ask that question
anyway so this is the remember the
scanning pattern that I showed you
earlier which is
um different data set function output
right this is the this is the
um different data same function right
the the DSL or the DDF I can't remember
the acronyms but that's what it is
right so we're gonna we're gonna create
a fake model but but ideally you would
actually have a model that exists it's a
pre-tained model it's probably sitting
in in its HD format if it's a
closed captioning not available
[Music]
hundred underscore 100
oh this is 100 million uh bike I'm just
creating entry I don't even actually do
this
that's cool yeah
so if I have 20 zeros and I don't want
to type in I can say this is so much
easier to read this isn't it
right this is 100 million entries that
I'm creating
right so yeah this is also the new uh
format you can actually do that so I'm
just creating a numpy array internally
so that this model now I can populate my
my
my object store and then I have A Lash
and over again since you
since they're saying it's the best
account is written into go ahead and
return to predict that
which I do
if I have my imaginary friend with me
okay so we're going to go and create a
particular model we're going to load the
model and then I have this function
called make model batch predictions
where I'm sending them all and this is
going to be my remote task and I'm going
to go ahead and send it a shot and Shard
is different data
same function
and all this data is going to read that
particular sharp data and it's going to
give it to model and since this model is
a closure it's callable I can actually
call that and it's going to return to
the result and I just return back the
result so that's what this particular
model does
and here's my taxi data
um I've just collected six months of
data it's about two or two or three
gigabytes and we have all this data
sitting over there
and I'm going to load the particular
model
and this returns me the closure or the
handle to the internal function and I'm
going to take that and do a put right
put the mode of an object store very
simple I'm just going to go ahead and
put in Object Store and I don't worry
about I won't worry about how this model
is going to be copied over to
12 different tasks that I originally
created
now I have 10 cores over here and I
created 12 tasks so some guy is going to
be waiting for the other person to
finish the correct
and each each file is is is about
31 50 megabyte or something anyway so
here's my list of references you're
going to come back
so these are all my shards
and I'm just going to go call the
prediction do you see what happens
so this is the the the Crux of the tasks
I'm calling my make model
prediction.remote with the mode of
reference remember I didn't send the
model itself I just sent a reference to
it right I just sent an object reference
if I sent a mortar money if you would
have happened
it will actually create a copy of that
particular model wherever the task is
here and that's just going to Lane you
were talking about you know I could
actually get out of memory here because
I'm I'm sending a copy of them anymore
but here I'm just sending a reference
which this model has been created go
figure out where to get it from
because then make a copy yes yes
because our our data is not that big but
is this a good example of like how you
use writing instead of jobless
yeah yeah you could you could use that
right for for small batch predictions
you want to do that and I think it's
very pytonic right I mean you could use
job living a good job there but if you
head to scan at some point
um this would make perfect sense
foreign
I ran all these things in parallel right
so when I do a get results I got all my
tips back
so this is doing batch inference at
scale
any questions
now
you guys want to do exercises no
all right Friday afternoon
but but
um if you really want to get into this
I would urge you I would implore you to
follow the instructions that I want to
get to install your own laptop some of
these people installed
it and you can contact me and say
s
okay so let's go to the next one next
notebook
um
where I'm talking about object
references now object references is one
of the other patterns that Ray allows
you to use and we saw a bit of it how
you actually do rate getting away put
and over here I'm going to explicitly
show how you actually do that an object
reference is this Distributing immutable
shared memory built on top of Apache era
so in memory format is quite efficient
and so if you actually have an arrow
object it's going to store as an error
if you have to do a pythony's in the
store is
High conversion of an object so it's
quite it's quite convenient that way
so here we are
I normally try to sort of do this
regularly because I
don't currently remind you so what I do
is I check to save raise initialized
from the previous incarnation if it is a
shutdown and start a new one
and since this is a laptop your
picture I don't know why this is telling
me to about money
oh I know I created another contact
environment and I think I'm kind of like
all right so here's a here's a numbness
all I'm doing is create a number list
I'm just going to go ahead and do a put
we'll send this right ready put and get
so we're changing object reference and
if I really want to do a get all I do is
just do a get and I give them a result
back very simple way of using this
particular
allow you to be able to do this and you
didn't have to worry about
creating a song okay you didn't have to
worry about it
protocol buffer I didn't have to worry
about where it is understeering getting
ready to put simply apis as long as it's
a very powerful thing and I think the
the Simplicity of these abstractions is
is what has really attracted a lot of
people to do this
effectively now I'm passing object
references right I can pop object
references now this is a little bit
subtlety over here so I'm creating an
echo of the radar remote and I'm just
going to go ahead and
print the value of x
and if I send in an object reference
then it's going to resolve automatically
and then print the value of that from
from the logic store so let's look at an
example I created this two objects
now pass that value I did pass a
reference by password value I just sent
y
and if Y is smaller than and
kilobytes it's just going to store in in
process memory not shared memory
um and you see that the current value it
was scheduled in this particular process
and the current value is 25.
I can send an object reference
and says oh I'm just I got an object
reference I'm going to now go to the
object store and fetch the value and I
should actually get the same value
that argument for that is thing because
I send an object reference which was
this bit over here and what was it this
was the list
now what if I actually sent past by
reference I don't want you to result
that I actually want you to send I'm
sending you a reference and the way you
actually do that and the reason you want
to use reference is that you might want
to pass this reference elsewhere so you
don't propagate that just say one
reference the one way to do that you
pass that as a dictionary so for example
over here I can pass that dictionary and
this function is not going to get the
value it's going to print out the
reference that you actually
and the difference subtle difference is
that if you just want to you don't want
the the function to um to resolve that
you just send in a dictionary with with
a particular value so you notice that
and then you might want to send this you
might want to send this object reference
elsewhere we'll just we'll see some
examples of it in a bit
okay any questions
okay simple API agree I disagree
now it is considerable that that you
might write a particular task
that's rang for a long time right and
you do you get on it and it's humble on
something but you want to make sure that
you're not on forever because radar get
into the block so yeah there's a way you
can actually Force radugget to timeout
in in certain instances and this
actually happens quite a bit so I'm
going to go ahead and create a log
function that's going to run for 10 and
return the answer to the universe and
I'm going to block I'm going to time out
of the six seconds
so when I do uh radar get for this
particular remote function that just
returns an object reference and we're
going to get on it and I should time out
after
too long and this is a common scenario
where you can
do more before timeouts that
I'll go ahead and do a shutdown
am I going too fast
yeah
there's a timeouts area is there any
uh
development
good question I mean if you if you want
to do particularly cleanup I think what
would you do is is
um
that's a good question let me think
about this is there a callback that you
can actually send to the timeouts and
the timeout is returning actually sends
you that particular call back
I have to get I have to get back into
that one but that's a good question
would you say were you saying it I want
to do some cleanup right I timeout the
other day well what you could do is when
you get an exception you could probably
handle handle over here
so the answer to your question is that
is there a built-in callback that you
can actually give to the uh to the API
because after this particular timeout
what you do is go ahead and invoke the
Callback alternatively you catch the
exception because you know you got a
tank on error and over here now they can
actually
this will be something very similar to
what you would do in Java finally right
you got an exception back and you do
that so in in this particular scenarios
not knowing the exact answer to your
question whether you can actually
provide callback I don't think the EP
actually has callbacks associated with
that but you can actually catch
exception in the New York New York
finally or or claim your resources in
this big of the code I'm concerned about
this happening
over and over again right
here
yeah yeah
so I would I I would put you know the
auxiliary utility functions over here
that the resources
but that's a good question I'm going to
check with my
my core team to see
if there is okay
um
let's go to the um the third one now
so I'm going to talk about actors
[Music]
right so actors is is uh said earlier
it's a way to create stateful functions
a stateful function that actually
maintain registers you have a class
and the class maintains a particular
State as you know and so you want to
maintain that state
each instance of the class gets attached
to a particular python worker so what
happens is that remember what I told
when I showed you a particular diagram
you actually had a worker process which
was running as as process in the node
when you create an instance of an actor
that particular actor is scheduled on
that particular worker process that
worker process now because an actual
process
right it assumes they have to process if
you create another instance of that then
you'll be attached to another one so you
can create multiple instances of
accurate there's a very common design
pattern to create multiple actors to
scale things out and the workflow is
that your driver or whichever program
actually executes that it's going to go
in invoke an instance of your class
called computer remote and it's going to
call a red light to say hey I want to
schedule this figure out where it is
right and Ray living cell go in and send
an RPC call to this particular actor
because it's got the resources that you
need going to do that it's a very simple
way do that you don't have to worry
about that but I just wanted to give you
what actually
happened and then once the actor comes
out uh now this is become an actor and I
can just
actually methods that I actually want
now the methods executed on the actor
are in the order in which you invoke
because you want to make sure that all
the methods for that particular instance
will be executed in the serial manner in
which you involve
now there's a way you can actually do
asynchronous because you might have a
reason to do a synchronous because I
don't want method Amen to be an entity
to be to the synchronously executed I
want them to be as synchronous executed
in that case what you do is you make the
act of their synchronous
so the order now is going to be
undetended well it won't be
deterministic it won't be in order to
meet you involved that
did I make that occur
synchronous actress will invoke the
methods in the mannering machine
if you don't like the older admission
you want to invoke those methods on that
particular actor then you can create
those functions there synchronously and
when it sees an asynchronous definition
for a function it's going to convert
that actor into it a synchronous model
usable
okay so let's let's do a very simple
example
of an actor
and let's create an actor that actually
does the method
that does a stateful actor pattern that
there's method tracking this might be a
use case in Telemetry let's say you
actually want to find out who is
invoking what particular function
rate or who is doing what imports and
you want to find out who actually called
what
um so this would be one way you can
actually write this particular
distributed application that is Method
tracking
now the example is is the illustration
is simple but the application is
University
so I'm creating a method State counter
and I decorated that very more which
means that hey red
sort this out man this is going to be
um a stateful function and I in my state
that I'm saying I have
um three
callers or three Bookers the Brokers are
going to use that I'm going to do the
I'm going to create an invoke method
I'll just keep pretending I'm doing
something but this is a generic example
and then I'm just going to update the
the the the person who actually invoked
me with the counter and I'm just going
to return the state of that in poker I'm
just going to do a get invoke state
which is another method that gives me
the the current state or that particular
invoker and then I'm just going to call
get all the workers which just gives me
the state of the entire
Telemetry dictionary that I have
very simple very platonic right
you're not using any of the software's
connection over here just using python
code and the only thing you've done is
just using that a radar remote
I'm going to create an instance of that
particular action so that sort of
returns me an instance of the particular
actor at this point now
uh this particular class is an instance
of an actor and it's scheduled somewhere
you don't have to worry about what this
number is this is internal for array
rail is exactly which melee is using it
but I just want to show you what what
actually happens when you do that you
don't have to worry about what the
bloody number is
business
and now I'm just randomly going to go
ahead and and create a name of the
choice and I'll just go ahead and do
word or invoke that remote with the name
of the argument so what I'm doing is I'm
invoking it's it's invoke method I'm
sending you the invoker who did that and
they would just go ahead and do that and
return return the value
so now I create a three invokers
and I'll go ahead and invoke randomly
who called what and I'll just bring
those numbers up
and so see what's called five times the
a was called three times a was called
four again because I went through the
same Loop you'd see that this is
actually maintaining a statement
invoking in real time is your
you didn't have to make an RPC call you
need to figure out where it's not that
Vector was we just did that all
automatically for you
then I can actually just fetch the
counters and this should be the same C
is six is five
B is four right state will maintain on
that particular
any questions
so we talked about tasks how you create
tasks how you schedule them remotely you
don't schedule them you just create a
task Ray world will be a schedule for
you how to get values back from a task
because every time you have nuclear
weapons and whether or your records will
materialize in your Object Store when
they're ready you can fetch that
and then you can do object store where
you can actually create object
references by the read it and record
and then you use the parameter um
and then you can actually use the array
actually to do that
another question I mean another
um another example about
parameter server anybody use parameters
or we're going to do this
so parameter server is sort of the old
pair line when I want to do distributed
training
the old Paradigm was that you actually
have the central server where your
workers are who are creating radiance
would publish those that would update
those gradients to the parameter server
so that when when the synchronization
actually happens up old
ml that's actually running in parallel
knows that who is created what gradients
that actually do the synchronization
today
really people actually use ground
rate and reduce where there is a way you
can actually synchronize actors
for example pie chart uses by default I
think we use a nickel x equals using
rabbit so this is a particle that
actually
does the gradients so when you're doing
distribute training and when you're
doing the step remove anybody partridge
program over here
but in partial today we we calculate the
gradient you go to the lots of many
you know the zero bread and then you do
up deadly Radiance and if it's a
distributed
um uh training they're doing then the
DDP protocol will do what we call
gradient synchronization
in the old days this was
this was done using parameter server
it's not all Paradigm you have a worker
that actually directly talks to the
parameter server it up it's a great
deals so that in the next training look
people are the individual workers will
get all the gradients were computed by
the other workers so they update their
internal gradient so now everybody's
actually in sync all the loss of
gradients that you
can workers
so very simple idea I'm creating a
remote class
I'm creating a parameter server I'm
initializing that with some
random gradients
I get the parameters which is which is
too cold and I update
data right now remember if you were
doing this in a class
python class you could actually just
make that as a property right so you can
just set that you can get attribute
currently Ray does not support the uh
the attribute function so you can't
sit and get you to have to do again
to get the the the the the
default attribute of value okay
so we're going to go ahead and Define
our request has two functions one does
it get Prime into the other one takes
the gradients from the worker
and I'm going to now create individual
workers right now these individual
workers could be a client or they could
be a function I decided to just write
individual workers at the task
and what does the
current what does the argument of the
worker is
is an instance of the handle to the
actor so that it knows that once I've
completed my gradient I'm going to
update that and the way you update that
it takes the parameter
cost is an argument of the my parameters
with this particular gradient that I've
posted
so over here this could be your training
functions that actually execute getting
more money box and then once it's
actually done the optimizer step and
it's got the gradient you can just put
the ingredients over here
but this is your your main worker look
that's training this is sort of going
for the import and I'm doing my
calculation I'm doing my loss I'm doing
my Optimizer I'm creating my predictions
I'm finding what my loss is I'm going to
update my gradients and then I'll tell
the parameter server update my gradients
right very simple
so I create a parameter server okay I
got an instance of that
uh let's find out what the initial
values are which are values are going to
be zero because that's what I instant
share the comments with
now I'm going to go ahead and create my
workers
I'll create five workers and I just use
very simple componential list very
pythonic and great pythonic in nature
right so I'll go ahead and create this
and I get my object references back
because I created three workers and then
for 20 iterations of that I'm just going
to go ahead and
I'm just going to go ahead and open the
problem
so now this is actually happening so if
I go to my uh
if I go to my um task I should actually
see this
okay
yeah here's the prominent server running
all the actors we share with you they've
got nothing confident I'm going to
server and Survey right so this is what
this is what that's what actually shows
me
[Music]
um
I haven't updated that to 2.1 metrics
but if I click on that if I hit install
graphite you get this amazing
pictures of metrics right what CPU is
executing what that's what the object
memory is what task is doing that all
the metrics now is part of 2.1
sharing a Blog link
with you momentarily
so that was that was the parameter
server we got 15 minutes
any questions over here
shut this down
now this is actually a good exercise for
you to do at home where you now just
change that particular method time to do
something else for example
and then create a computer random value
and then keep track of
them when you do an invoke you just
calculate some random value when you're
25.
and send you the value
so this is actually a good homework
exercise where you do
and if you want to cheat
Solutions are there
did you see the solutions directory
that's the first thing students do
is there Solutions available
maybe I should do underscore description
okay
I want to cover one more notebook
because we have 15 minutes and I promise
that I'm gonna end and I and I didn't
make a pact with you that we're going to
go through at least the first module
which I did
so don't hold me accountable for them so
I did finish it
but I'm going to go to this next one
that that is the Revisited lecture
Revisited because a few things that I
want you to
um go home with it
the pattern that I talked about earlier
that race support is called the tree
actual patterns and this is a very
pattern that that internally Ray uses it
quite a bit so in training and tuning we
actually create a supervisor actor and
the supervised actor could be Humane
China and then this trainer actually
creates a local actor and the work actor
is the one that actually does the
training
if this was a hyper chronic agunity we
would actually have one trainer that
actually
the supervisor and it creates a each and
every trainer and each and every trainer
will actually create tasks
rather than third slide I talked about
so this is a very common
how to log in in the internal
implementation array but a lot of people
actually use that to write their own
distributed application because this is
what we call the tree of actors because
you're actually creating a tree your
actress as you do that
and this is not dissimilar to what we've
done over here
saying paid a different function so I'm
using the same data but I have a trainer
that actually does does
the the function
okay so let's look at what I mean by
this so I'm going to go ahead and import
my stuff
do the bit about
initializing and
we're going
I'm just dying to know how oh yeah
I won't sleep tonight
okay
so here's an example of what I'm doing
is is I'm creating a mortal Factory and
I have a water Factory that given a
particular function is going to return
you the model type that I want to train
and then the model type can be when it's
draining it could be in any one of these
three states right could be running it
could be pending or it could be done
this is just a similar that I'm doing a
training in parallel my model is nothing
but some mistake that actually gets the
model and string the type of model that
I want and the function it's you know
objective functions or loss function or
whatever function you want to do to
compute the metrics that would be that
particular function and when I do a
train I just invoke that particular
function
like to do the to the gradient
computation to compute the loss or
whatever whatever however you want to
train this could be a python a training
function this could be XG boost this
could be your second alarm training that
you're going to use any one of that but
this sort of a generalized framework
that actually
so that's sort of my class that I've
created
and this doesn't have to be a remote
my regular python class
so we do that
and then I'm going to create a go ahead
and create a worker
and the worker now takes in
as I say the motor function it takes the
current state it is in I Define whatever
current state is
and then when I say go ahead and do the
work I'm just going to go in and create
it's going to create a it'll create an
instance of a particular fact
you would send the model that you want
and it would and it will it will
um enroll this footage of the train
function so this sort of a composable
API you know what's actually happening
over here is I'm creating a model
Factory with the candle model that I
want
function that we want and then go ahead
and invoke a string function so this
returns me back a model that I Define up
here and it's going to call its training
function
so now this isn't going to run very
simple
very pythonic
so here's my supervisor I'm creating
these are my
these are my training functions that I
create now I know this is a simple
example but this is a good illustrator
framework that tells you that you can
actually plug in you can plug in
whatever you actually want over here but
it's just a little illustration level
than that and it's perfect for um
doing quick quick exercises to fill in
the blanks do whatever function that you
want
and my supervisor is the one that's
going to create an instance of
tree workers
linear regression
classification or neural network right
and then I have three functions which I
associate with that so this is going to
create my instance of three workers
work will actually go and invoke this
pretty good worker
right in the number of workers that I
have remember all that this this is this
is a lot of things actually happening
over here I'm doing a workout remote
boom
for each worker in the sales workers now
I'm actually invoking the remote
function and if actually want to turn it
it'll let you just iterated to the list
determine your little skill you don't
have control mean at this I just want to
illustrate because otherwise this will
go on forever but I just you can
actually kill an actual instance by just
giving the reference to it and it'll
actually killed that but when you do
array of shutdown you actually kills it
all right so that's my supervisor
um and I'm going to go ahead and create
a supervisor over here which I did
and
here's my super die remote and if I go
to the dashboard
can't see the gray supervisor so green
workers that's really working
enchantment yeah three actors which are
running
right there and where are we
and I'm gonna stop doing the training
so what I've done is I'm just going to
the pretty good Loop by saying you know
go ahead and get me the states of all
the workers which are actually running
and if they've changed their state to be
done then I'm done I'll just get out of
that let's go ahead and the result is
true for old done I just turned into all
the workers and if you look at the
output that's actually what's what's
doing
so it's actually running in a
distributed manner running to record
this could be running 100 core on a
remote machine and that worker will be
running once it's actually done
and you invoke them into site you'll get
it ready for the state and we are done
any questions
I want to do final example every 10
minutes I think
now remember we talked about
um inference using tasks right you can
actually use the same thing using actors
the advantages of using the actors is
because say you've actually doing a bash
inference on a GPU
now GPU requires you to actually take
some weights that you actually have and
then put it in GPU memory right and you
actually want to maintain that when you
can stay and in my task for example if
you recall I actually had the the depth
of a natural audio that underscores for
I had certain state that I was
maintaining that I wanted that good
propagated so instead of me for five
vectors that I create instead of loading
the the weight for the model five
different times I just do it once and
then gets copied over
so there's an advantage of maintaining a
state over here I maintained state in
the actor so then the actor can can use
the same if if somebody else calls that
particular connector the model is there
and so we're going to do exactly the
same thing over here so I'm going to go
ahead and create six actors
for my for my inference matching and I
had 12 shards
um same idea over here I'm going to go
ahead and
in the load model
which is our closure
and I'm going to create the New York
bash predictor and what this particular
does is loads the particular model at
this point I have an instance of
operating a model for their particular
clients I'll read the benefit shorter
than I am so he gets a copy of that same
function different data so it's the same
model the same python worker predictor
is going to be scheduled and is going to
use a different data set
I'm going to invoke his model with my
data frame so it's going to return with
the prediction and I return the
prediction back
very similar but except I'm using actors
over here and I'm using a pool log
Vector so
the gray will efficiently do that
I'll go and load my model which exactly
do the same thing at good times can I
just put it in memory and now I'm going
to do the same thing I did with the
tasks
uh my input shards are here
I'm going to create an actor pool now
there's a constitutical actor pool that
says go ahead and create
and that Ray will
schedule the next house those of you who
are using multi-processor however you
use multi-crossor support in Python very
similar concept we actually create a
pool of processes and then book a map
function on that and it
just scheduled the particular function
on that particular process the idea is
very similar over here
and we want to make sure that the ideas
were were identical so moving from
python moving from python
multi-processors to activate
multi-processor is easy because you know
you are familiar with the concept that
you have a mental image of of how to do
math and submit and all that and what
you return back and how to get executed
is where they identical so the transfer
of information the transfer was killed
around some knowledge you have a minimal
friction and that's the whole point
there's a whole point of writing great
apis so the transition becomes
relatively easy
okay
so let's go ahead and create
[Music]
um
number of actors and I'm sending them
order reference again same thing over
there I created a task over here I just
created
um the actors and then once I get all
these instances of accurate I'm going to
go ahead and create an actual pool so
these are the number of actors we can
back as references I'm going to send
those
to the actual pool
I do
this
and now I'm just going to submit you
know using the Lambda function I'm going
to go ahead and submit
to the active pool a remote chart to do
the protection
very similar now this might take a
little while because I only have 12 and
I only have six actors
right instead of 12 I could have just
used 12 and I would just use all the
CPUs
but this is where Jensen may ask but how
do you tune this thing you just play
around with it right to see and how many
how many cores you want to sign
now if this was a GPU if this was
prediction this was an image reference I
was doing a prediction on GPU I can
actually provide when I create an actor
I can say use a fraction of a particular
GPU so the regulator would actually
schedule that actor on a note that
actually has a GPU and then it will
actually run on a GPU so you can specify
where you actually by default to run on
CPU but this was a python prediction
that you were doing some intimate
segmentation and you wanted to use GPU
reference you can specify in the um in
the actor
method saying when you say radar remote
I can actually say GPU equal to four and
it will it will run on those four gpus
so when I run that that's going to run
the prediction
and we're done
right yeah because there's very support
the gpus
oh no the the yeah
I know I know um we're sort of working
on it but yeah if you have a if you
yeah I I haven't been successfully been
able to run into GPU because the way
they've actually done you know the Asic
chip doesn't really give you the GPU but
I don't know how that can be good but
yeah if you have an AWS if you have
uh
yeah yeah so you can just create a GPU
and then you'll actually see it see it
running on gpus
okay so recap actors are stateful
um
entities in rate they allow you to
use active tools to schedule your your
worksters you can actually do references
you can actually create Trio characters
to do distributed training
um and the three actor pattern is
something quite popular and quite
ubiquitous and um
in in using
a distributed computing pattern using
what we actually talked about
um
given that we're out of time I'm not
going to go with this third example
which is very similar to what we
actually did with the parameter server
but over here I'm just writing a very
simple log service where I'm actually
picture and I'm sending the worker if
you've seen this before right
we have said this before this is very
similar to the parameter so we'll have
time is just
created a worker you can do the same
thing and I've created
that's why I'm asking a question what
does this remind you of previous lessons
probably the survey it's exactly the
same
but now I'm writing a mess
very simple way you can just write this
in a very pytonic way and in none of the
code that I've written I have to worry
about
the socket ground to worry about all
that
the only thing I had to worry about if I
was running this if my laptop that I'm
working on was connecting to a ray
cluster or any scale cluster what I'd be
doing in the rain and provide the IP
address of end mode and that's all I
have to do so I've extended my laptop
to run these things on
on the um cluster right if I'm running
it from a Jupiter notebook I do the same
thing if I'm running from Vizio code I
do the same thing if I remember you
probably show us crypto doing something
that's the beauty of that you're
actually doping on your laptop but
you're extending your laptop to be able
to actually scale those things and
invariably
most of the people who are actually
doing machine learning code
um we'll do it on the laptop because
the Simplicity of something new that a
laptop is so far more attractive than
doing SSH to AWS cluster and try
all that's actually management
or managed by Ray